Fox News Alert for you we've exclusive
new details tonight on this show about
the case of conservative activist Hayden
Williams he was attacked you might
remember well trying to recruit
conservatives at UC Berkeley harmik
Dillon is an attorney she represents
Williams and she joins us tonight with
the latest Army thanks a lot for coming
on so this was caught on tape it should
be fairly straightforward what what do
we know well Zachary greenberg who is
not a student at UC Berkeley but sort of
floats around on the campus assaulted
hated Williams on the video that you
know has gone viral all over the country
without provocation cold-cocked him and
you know Hayden has sustained injuries
to his face as a result of that and his
phone so after about 10 days the police
did arrest mr. greenberg and he was
arraigned in court today on three felony
charges of assault battery violent
threats and then also a disruption of
the phone as a misdemeanor and he pled
not guilty so that's what happened in
court today though there'll be an
upcoming court date in about a month for
a preliminary hearing and it'll be
interesting to see what his defense is
because it is very clearly him on the
video so he must have something else in
mind in terms of his defense but he has
a private attorney not a public defender
and I've done some digging and I've
learned a few other interesting facts
about mr. greenberg and his history with
with the court system so give us give us
a flavor what those might be
so mr. greenberg over the past couple of
years has had numerous incidents Reis
filed restraining orders against his
roommates in multiple group houses and
then moved out of those group houses his
roommates have have put in evidence that
has been more believable and believed by
the court that none of those incidents
happened he's also had a restraining
order filed against him by a former
roommate which was granted by a court
and as a result of that restraining
order he had to turn in his guns to the
authorities he has filed several
lawsuits against landlords for charges
that were later dismissed by the court
and found not to be valid and he has
filed small claims claims against
roommates again found not to be
sustained for the most part and so
you know I like almost a dozen lawsuits
that I've uncovered that this man is
involved in and interestingly Tucker
this is a tactic actually that I've seen
used in another case involving a
Berkeley violent activist so you've had
a vet falaka on your show and falaka has
filed false restraining orders against
conservatives on the Berkeley campus you
know that there's a case that I'm
involved and that's now in the Court of
Appeals on that where we defeated a
false restraining order by her so I
think this is one of the growing tactics
of the left potentially is doing this
and he does this with fee waivers so
he's isn't paying the fees claiming that
he's indigent and he has no visible
means of support but his his uh his
lawyer told the reporters today outside
the courtroom that he is was on the
campus studying in the library but not
as a Berkeley student but studying
somewhere else so there's a lot yet to
be known about this guy what motivated
him but clearly he has anger issues one
of the people in the lawsuits described
you know marijuana use and certainly
there there's a gun at least one gun
involved in his possession and so a lot
of a lot more to be asked about this guy
and you know how he has private counsel
and why is he pleading not guilty so I
know we'll see what a private lawyer
another angry rich kid or an awful lot
of an awful lot of those on the left is
you know yeah great great to see you
thank you very much